[Music]
now to the GQ Men of the Year party
where one of Time Magazine's silence
breakers Terry Crews opened up for the
first time about why he is suing his
alleged sexual assault er this is the
deal you say I'm sorry when you step on
someone's foot by mistake but when you
stab him I'm sorry's not enough that's
what the lawsuit it's about
accountability in the complaint filed
against Hollywood agent Adam Bennett
Cruz claims that last year then it
allegedly groped him quote so hard that
Cruz left back in pain adding he stared
at him quote like a rabid dog Bennett
has not commented on the allegations and
I'm telling you I'm not playing
there is no backing down there is no
backward we're gonna take this all the
way I'm gonna make sure no one ever ever
ever has to go through what I went
through on the GQ carpet the 49 year old
actor was joined by his wife of 27 years
Rebecca
this man has endless energy and proved
it with a jump in front of photographers
crews told et on lines lauren zima how
humble he is that time included so many
brave voices in the person of the year
issue amongst those other women's those
courageous women are the reason I spoke
out in the first place right now this is
more than just a fad or a movement a lot
of those predators are just sitting
tight and being very quiet and hoping
this all goes away but it ain't gonna go
away
[Music]
you
[Music]